devin larritt you son of a [ __ ] that's
freaking
what's the matter
mit got you pushing too many pencils all
right you got me
if i wanted to beat you what would i do
here
it starts before we even arm wrestle
it's it's all postural really
so
if i can
make you come to me
this is the first step always make me
come to you
exactly it lets you use more muscles
against less muscles you target weakness
right you target my fingertips you get
to use more muscles
so you see this ridge
yeah very important
the higher up this ridge is in my hand
the better
the more the pressure is in my fingers
as opposed to your fingers the better
right
what are some basics here though
okay maybe we'll start with a move
called the post
the post
by itself is not that powerful of a move
but it's a fantastic opening
once you have a post established
the world completely opens up for you
yeah the post
is very simply
an upwards drive of the knuckles
yeah and then also yes climbs at this
point yes exactly and it's all about
generating better angles that's it yeah
you're always trying like if you open up
your hand you're always trying to get
deeper as well so you're trying to get
deeper and deeper climbing up and over
both yeah
that's it advancing that position all
the time
yeah
so you're always climbing you're always
coming over and yeah that's the goal
yeah
always climbing always improving
position abc
always be climbing
so basically inside and outside that'll
be our first division so when we're when
we're arm wrestling outside
basically just it's all these pulling
motions pulling pulling
uh and to some degree they all attack
the fingers okay
a standard top roll will look something
like this i'll start to apply pressure
up into the fingers
i'll start to bend my wrist and as i'm
bending my wrist you will be attempting
to bend your wrist and i will block you
with something called pronation which is
this turning
and i'll carry through the fingers
and i'll take you all the way to the pin
pads through the fingertips
it's it's a fantastic move for for
beating people it's one of the best
techniques in arm i've seen the top row
most world champions i would say
i'd say most use top rule yeah i also
seen you compliment somebody that
you know
it's not over here yet no
you can hold some of the strongest
people in the world like this and that's
you i think you were complimenting
somebody that they were able to do that
against yeah another way to talk about
arm wrestling like so we started touch
on like the top roll the hook
so a hook is basically
uh wrist flexor driven
right so it's more about attacking the
person's pronation so you establish a
hook
and then you can pull out of it
or you make it more of a press and it's
more shoulders coming right forward and
you're coming right in
okay
so hooking and pressing are still all
the moves in arm wrestling are similar
okay just subtle differences but the
role results in an asymmetric like i'm
losing your weight right it feels like
the hook is where you get to stay in the
match a little bit more
you do yeah but a good a good arm
wrestler
isn't going to necessarily give you that
like they're they're not you don't see a
lot of world-class matches
where the guy is just pressing you don't
see it the controversial kings move what
is that
okay so the king's move is actually it's
a defensive move
okay so the only thing i'm trying to do
when i kings move
is i'm trying to attack your arm angle
through dragging
okay
and i'm trying to target your fingers
through pronation i'm trying to do all
the other things as well but these are
my anchors okay so i'll fight for all
those stuff but i'll give them away
this is the one that i hold so i will
turn
right and a lot of times there's a
dipping
okay
so are you pulling also i am are you
like basically pulling me towards you
i'll try
but i may not be able to so
normally a king's move is used against a
very strong opponent the king's move has
thrown a big wrench
yeah into into the sport
but there's this has been happening a
lot as the sport evolves the king's move
is here to stay where is where do the
injuries come right here
that's the one the bad one is the break
is the break of one yeah
humorous oh wow yeah right here yeah so
literally break your test your frame man
we are we're like
so not a bicep tear not it can't happen
bicep tears can happen
i'd say that the break is the one that's
a little arm break oh yeah
and when it goes it's like
yep
wow the strongest arm i've ever felt in
my life
he's not even trying i'm very
specialized i'm a super specialized
athlete ladies and gentlemen devin
larritt this is a huge honor today
right there hold on come on give me
[Music]
[Applause]
you